&gt;&gt; Notice that I have y and y in both of these equations. That means I can
substitute negative 2x plus 4 in for y. This is my substitution step. Next we
distribute a positive 3 to negative 2x and positive 4, so I'll have negative 6
plus 12. Combining like terms, I'll have negative 1x plus 12 equals 10. I have
negative 6x's and positive 5x's. I have more negatives than I do positives, so
when I simplify here, I know that I'm going to need a negative number, a
negative 1x. So I have negative 1x equals negative 2. So if the negative of x
equals negative 2, then the positive of x must equal positive 2. Some students
think about multiplying both sides by negative 1 and others divide by negative
1. Either way is correct. We know x equals 2, but we're not done. We still need
to find y. To find y, I'm going to use one of my original equations. I've used
the first one since it looks less complicated. Notice also that I didn't choose
to use this equation. I might have made a mistake when trying to find this
equation. That's why it's always best to use an original one. Plugging in 2 for
x, I'll have 4 is equal to 4 minus y, then I can subtract 4 from both sides to
isolate my y. So 0 equals negative y, which means 0 also equals positive y. Any
number multiplied by 0 is still 0. So, if we multiply by negative 1, this should
make sense. The point 2 comma 0 should be the point of intersection. If I use
some mental math real quick, we can check it. 2 times 2 is 4, and 4 minus 0 is
4. So yes, this one checks. Plugging in 2 for x and 0 for y, I'll have 5 times 2
which is 10. This term would be 0, so 10 equals 10. That's true as well.